[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right this is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far hundreds of challengers not one
winner
nobody has caught us making a mistake
because you don't make them yeah well
tonight a fan named Ben Ratner thinks he
caught a mistake he says it happened
when I was discussing the video that the
city of Fresno made in response to my
offer to give them our giant Conan
bobblehead Fresno made a video they sent
it to us I showed it on the air and then
I made some comments about it Ben claims
I used the wrong legal term hi Conan
been here and I think I finally found an
error on your show it's about the fresno
bobblehead video that you posted a
couple of days ago when they put you on
a merry-go-round as a cardboard cutout
you sit there putting your cardboard
cutout on a merry-go-round with slander
because it made you look weird and
creepy which makes me look like a creep
and a weirdo
that's classic defamation of character
Fresno you owe me 25 million dollars for
slander regardless of the fact that you
don't need a cardboard cutout to make
you look ridiculous defamation of
character does not fall under slander in
this case slander requires the defendant
to have malicious intent and I don't
think there was one bad thing about that
video
slander must also be spoken or gestured
none of which they did to you this would
fall under libel which includes recorded
images so Conan I hope you get to talk
this one over with your lawyers and
please don't count this against my
internship application
Wow
well sorry Ben but you are completely
wrong the city of Fresno did in fact
slander me
they made malicious statements that
weren't just spoken they were sung let
me explain when this video arrived we
had our audio team analyze it in great
detail that's just standard procedure
shut up
when we removed the Beach Boys music
there was a different song underneath
[Music]
Colon's a perv and a murderer too you
can call it slander with all of its true
murderer
[Music]
Conan O'Brien that's indeed what he is
[Applause]
lemon oh yeah a subliminal message
saying by a turn-of-the-century Center
with a beautiful voice angelic voice
one more thing Ben besides you being
wrong
I noticed you go to Ithaca College okay
well just so happens we have a number of
interns this semester from Ithaca
College this is completely true a lot of
interns from Ithaca College and I asked
them to come out here right now
there's our college interns interns I I
believe you have Ben's internship
application with you got it right here
at Conan very nice and there we go
well there you go then so much for
school he'll be more than happy to screw
one of her ho knows how they'll do as
they're told exactly the challenge still
stands people if you think you've
spotted an era on our show reported at
team koco.com / haha I found an error we
will sort it out right here on the air
let's see if you've got what it takes to
make chutney out of the maestro